we don't know what sort of damage this  virus could do if it were to spread in a  country with a weaker health system we  must act now to help countries prepare  for that possibility for all of these  reasons I am declaring a public health  emergency of international concern over  the global outbreak of novel : of a  corona virus the main reason for this  declaration is not because of what is  happening in China but because of what  is happening in other countries our  greatest concern is the potential for  the virus to spread to countries with  weaker health systems and which are ill  prepared to deal with it let me be clear  this declaration is not a vote of  no-confidence in China  on the contrary whu-oh continues to have  a confidence in China's capacity to  control the outbreak I'll repeat this  let me be clear this declaration is not  a vote of no-confidence in China  on the contrary whu-oh continues to have  confidence in China's capacity to  control the outbreak